joining me now is one of the first
elected officials to stand up to the
lies
and to all the goalpost shifting of the
medical cartel
florida governor ron desantis governor i
remember
early on there were a few governors
brian kemp
you christy gnome a few others were just
trashed by a lot of the people that we
just showed in those clips
for your dangerous approach to this
dangerous pandemic
a year later almost what do you see
well uh laura in florida in terms of
coronavirus
we have less coronavirus per capita
in terms of deaths than the national
average and we have the second oldest
population
in the united states we have less cases
per capita than the national average and
yet
we have all schools open we have all
businesses able to operate
everyone has a right to work our
unemployment's below the national
average our tax revenue
is much higher than expectations and so
i think what we've learned is two things
one
when you deal with a pandemic it doesn't
mean that every other issue in society
simply goes away you have to deal with
folks ability to earn a living
to educate their kids and mental health
and well-being
but what we've also learned is these
lockdowns on their own just don't work
even if you didn't care about economy
even if you didn't care about
education they don't work to stop the
spread
and i think the results in florida and
elsewhere
show that people want to come here
because they know we're a free state
and i think that the the facts have
borne us out to have made the right
decisions
i want to move on to what happened in
manatee county where
i think you offered 3 000
uh vaccines to mostly i believe it was
mostly to the senior community
but for that your critics lashed out at
you
take a look the optics
are really really bad if we were going
to pick and choose
who was going to be vaccinated ahead of
everyone else
i would hope it would go to the
underserved populations you're taking
the whitest demographic the richest
demographic
in manatee county and putting them ahead
of everyone else
governor it's racist to follow the
science and vaccinate the most
vulnerable population
i don't understand this now we're
checking uh boxes of ethnicity and color
i thought it was about the science
saving lives well look
we we were the first state to reject the
cdc guidance was which wasn't going to
put seniors first and we said no no
we're putting seniors first
i was criticized by the same types of
folks for putting seniors first well
guess what florida seniors are glad
that we put them first today's event
where we have the 3 000
seniors that was over and above what
that county had been getting we saw that
there was
that we needed to get more seniors in
that particular county so we worked with
some of the local neighborhoods and said
where is a lot of seniors where can we
go in
and knock out several thousand very
quickly to get those numbers up and i
can tell you
laura there were an awful lot of very
happy seniors there today there are a
lot of smiles on their faces
people were able to get vaccines this is
one of many things that we're doing
to put seniors first in florida we're
not going to stop
until every senior that once a shot gets
a shot and we're not going to let some
of the naysayers slow us down
governor desantis breaking news tonight
the fbi u.s attorney's office also
are reportedly investigating governor
cuomo's handling of nursing homes
and it's apparently in its very early
stages but
your thoughts on again criticism you got
and the praise
cuomo got from the likes of dr fauci
well if you go back to march i was
getting criticized for not closing the
beaches
which you don't close beaches for a
respiratory virus so
i was right on that but the media
totally ignored how the governors were
handling the nursing homes
we did an order right at the beginning
saying hospitals cannot discharge
covid positive nursing home residents
back to nursing homes
by doing that we saved hundreds if not
thousands of lives
and so we made the right decision at the
outset and again the facts have borne us
out over these many months
and governor finally i know you were
very close to rush limbaugh
he praised you in his final show i know
how much he admired you
and he had great hopes for your
political future your thoughts tonight
he's the babe ruth of radio he would
have been great in radio lori
without the conservatives and he was
just that talented obviously he's a
conservative icon up there with people
like scalia and reagan and buckley
and he was a personal friend you know
him he's a warm
and decent man and uh we're really proud
that he
was in the southern command down in
florida for so long we're going to miss
him tremendously
he was a great guy he was ahead of the
curve and leaving new york city and
coming to florida i remember he told me
what was it 20 years ago ingram why are
you paying the taxes in uh
in d.c moved to florida i'm like uh who
wants to go to florida who's
now he's proven once again house just
think laura though
just think of how many tens of millions
of dollars
he saved over his 23 years in the state
of florida
and so it was the right decision and we
were so glad to have him he was great
for the community down there and people
loved him
all right governor thank you so much
tonight and for those thoughts